ميدانيا ومن داخل اوكرانيا فلت الاداره
العسكريه في اقليم خار كيف بمقتل 49 شخصا
في قصف روسيا استهدفا استهدف مقهى ومحلا
تجاريا في احدى قرى منطقه كوبي
ولمتابعه تفاصيل معنا منزابيل مراسلنا
الياس
نعم بالفعل 15% من سكان هذه القريه قريه
تيجروزا قتلوا في ضربه واحده ذلك اننا
نتحدث عن قريه صغيره لا يتعدى عدد سكانها
330 شخصا وبحسب الحصيله التي افادت بها
الاداره العسكريه في اقليم خار كيف نحن
نتحدث عن 49 قتيلا وسبعه جرحى الاداره
العسكريه تقول بان نحو 60 شخصا كانوا
موجودين في المتجر الذي استهدف عصر هذا
اليوم بطبيعه الحال خدمه الطوارئ الحكوميه
تعمل على ازاله الانقاض المتبقيه بحثا
ربما عن مزيد من القتلى او الجرحى في هذا
القصف الذي يعتبر بانه غير مسبوق على
الاقل في اطار اقليميه خارج منذ اندلاع
هذه الحرب حتى الان لم تشهر الاداره
العسكريه في اقليم خار كيف حول طبيعه هذا
الهجوم وما الذي
تم بواسطته استهداف هذا المتجر بمعنى هل
كانت هذه غاره جويه ام صواريخ باليستيه
بعيده المدى ام انها صواريخ جراد او غيرها
من المقذوفات الصاروخيه التحقيقات ما زالت
جاريه هنالك اعداد كبيره من افراد الشرطه
الاوكرانيه التي وصلوا الذين وصلوا الى
المكان بالاضافه الى نحو 60 مسعفا يعملون
على اجلاء الجرحى معظمهم سوف ينقلون بحسب
السلطات الاوكرانيه الى مستشفيات
هذه المدينه حيث ان هذه المستشفيات ربما
تكون مختصه في مثل هذه الحالات هنالك
ادانات ايضا في داخل اوكرانيا على المستوى
السياسي من عدد من المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
الذين يصفون هذا الهجوم بالوحش وبجريمه
الحرب الرئيس الاوكراني وصف ذلك بالعمل
الوحشي والارهابي وكذلك ايضا مدير ديوانه
اندريه ايرماك
اوكرانيا ذهب الى القول بان
المطلوب الان من قاده الدول الاوروبيه دعم
اوكرانيا في تعزيز دفاعاتها الجويه
ووسائطها الجويه من اجل توفير الحمايه
لمدنها وقراها في وجه هذه الهجمات نحن
نتحدث عن هجوم كبير او بحياته الكثير من
سكان هذه القريه كما اشرت 15% من سكان هذه
القريه قتلوا في ضربه واحده وربما العدد
مرشح ايضا للارتفاع في قادم الساعات
شكرا جزيلا لك